موضوع فقره وقفه مع الحدث مع زميل وسيم
الدالي في اول رد فعل اذا الى للكريم لان
على ارسال هذا النوع من الاسلحه الثقيله
الى كيف من قبل المانيا والولايات المتحده
اهلا بك وسيم الدالي هل يعتبر بالتالي
تسليم هذه الدبابات الثقيله الهجوميه
الالمانيه والامريكيه لاوكرانيا تجاوز
للخطوط الحمراء التي حددتها موسكو
وبالتالي الدخول في مواجهه مباشره للدول
الغربيه مع روسيا نعم همم
الموقف الذي تتبناها موسكو انا الدول
الغربيه تتزايد عمليه الانخراط لها في ال-
همم المعارك في الحرب بين اوكرانيا بين
روسيا حتى ان عدد من الاصوات السياسيه
داخل همم البلدان الغربيه تحذر من هذا
الانخراط الذي يؤدي الى تصعيد والى انزلاق
نحو ما يسمى بالمواجهه المباشره بين
القوات الغربيه وبين روسيا طبعا همم الغرب
ينظر الى هذه العمليه من منطقه الدفاع
الشرعي المشترك وبالتالي يعتبر ان روسيا
ليست لها اي اساس لا تعتمد على اي اساس
قانوني لكي تتمكن من وصف الدول الغربيه
بانها دول مشاركه بشكل مباشر في النزاع
ال- الاوراني طبعا الخبراء القانون يقولون
ان همم يقولون ان المحامين يعتمدون اكثر
على اتفاقيات جنيف وعلى ميثاق الامم
المتحده وتحديدا على الماده الواحده
والخمسين من هذا الميثاق بعمليه التهديد
السن والاخلاف به
الوقوع اي عمل عدائي وهو كذلك يعتمدون على
الصوابق القضائيه لمحكمه العدل الدوليه
ولي المحكمه الجنائيه السابقه لغوزلافيا
السابقه
هذه القراءات وهذه قدمت حتى الى المعهد
العسكري الفرنسي تقول ان
التقديم السلاح من قبل اي دوله او الدعم
همم او تدريب القوات الاجنبيه او تقديم
المعلومات حتى المشارك تذهب هذه القراءه
حتى المشاركه بشكل شخصي وفردي لاحد رعايه
هذه الدول في في دوله في حاله حرب لا
يعتبر مشاركه بشكل مباشر ولا تعتبر هذه
الدوله طرفا في النزاع المسلح ونتحدث في
هذا الحال على همم عن روسيا واوكرانيا
طبعا من الناحيه القانونيه التحتيه يعتبر
الخبراء ان همم ان تم الاستناد الى نص
قانوني فان الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا يعتبر
في حد ذاته خرقا لكل النصوص القانونيه
والمواثيق الدوليه لكن السؤال الذي يطرح
الان
ماذا عن
المساعدات من حيث الطائرات المقاتله التي
طلبتها اوكرانيا في هذه الحال
وماذا سيجر عنه من خلال طبيعه المشاركه
الغربيه في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه طبعا
حدد الخطوط الحمراء من اول الحرب وقال ان
اي دوله تفرضها منطقه حضر حضر لمنطقه
الطيران في الاجواء الاوكرانيه فهي تعتبر
مساهمه بشكل اساسي في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه كذلك ايضا تقول همم يقول وزير
الدفاع ان هذا هو الهدف الاساسي لاوكرانيا
من اول الحرب خاصه وانا اقل همم نحن كنا
نريد المقاتلات الطائرات المقاتله من
الاول لكن عرفنا انهم السابق لاواني طلب
هذه الطائرات ولكن بالحصول على انظمه
الصواريخ والدبابات يمكننا الحصول على
طائره المقاتله وهذا مقد يخيف بعض الاصوات
السياسيه الغربيه فيما يتعلق
بالامدادات من الاسلحه وخاصه ان هولندا
وافقت على تقديم الطائرات وكذلك يدور نقاش
في الولايات المتحده حاليا حول مد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى طيب نسيم او
وسيم عفوا كيف تستعد روسيا لما تصرفه
بالحرب التي يشرونها الغرب بالوكاله
الاستعدادات من الواضح على المستوى الخطاب
هناك اشارات بان روسيا تستعد تاخذ على
محمل الجد وتستعد همم بشكل جاد من خلال
التصريح الذي قدمه السير الى وزير
الخارجيه يوم قبل ثلاث ايام وقال ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا لم تعد حرب هجينه حرب بين
الروس والغرب لم تعد حرب هجينه وانما حرب
شبه حقيقيه على المستوى الاجرائي هناك عدد
اشارات من خلال مثلا
تغيير همم قائد عمليات ال- ال- الجيش
الروسي همم في همم اوكرانيا وكذلك
اصلاحات هيكليه وسي- اساسيه في الجيش
الاوكراني همم الى همم كذلك هناك تحت
انشاء مناطق عسكريا خاصه المنطقه العسكريه
في موسكو والمنطقه العسكريه في صنفير وهي
تدخل في نطاق المنطقه العسكريه في روسيا
وهن نتحدث عن الداخل الروسي وهذا يشير الى
ان روسيا تستعد الى احتمال وجود همم هجوم
همم من قبل من قبل اطراف اخرى مشاركه في
الحرب الاوكرانيات كذلك همم تستعد روسيا
باستغلال الفرصه بما يتعلق
بالوقت الذي سيتاخر من خلال امدادات
الدبابات والتدريب بتاع موقع تعزيز موقعها
في مثلا في ميليتو بول وفي ماريو بول همم
تعزيز التوقيعها العسكري هناك حتى ان همم
قائد القوات المسلحه الامريكيه وصف بان
روسيا في الواقعه هي الان همم تحرز اسبقيه
ميدانيه ويستبعد ان حتى بهذه الامدادات
العسكريه الجديده يستبعد ان تتحرك الخطوط
نحو الوراء النحو الخلف من قبل القوات
الروسيه في عام 2013
على هذه الوقفه التحيه شكرا لك شكرا